الى الولايات المتحده حيث اعلنت سلطات ان
عملاء مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه القول
القبض على المشتبه به في قضيه وصفت بانها
اكبر عمليات تسريب لوثائق حكوميه سريه من
جهه قال وزير العد الامريكيين المشتبه به
يدعى
ويعمل مع الحرس الوطني بينما ذكرت وسائل
اعلام انه اختصاصي في تقنيه المعلومات في
الحرس الوطني وانه سيمثل امام المحكمه
اليوم
من جهه اقل المتحدثه باسم الفينتاجون ان
الوثائق التي سربت حساسه وانما حدث جريمه
متعمده ورفض المتحدث باسم تنتاغون مناقشه
تفاصيل الوثائق المسربه بسبب حساسيتها
وتاثيرها على الامن القومي والحلفاء
والشركاء حسب تعبيره واوضح ان لدى
البنتاجون قواعد صارمه للحفاظ على الوثائق
السريه وان العمل متواصل مع الوكالات
الفيدراليه لمعرفه الضرر الذي احدثه
التسريب
من امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في بوسطن تنضم
الينا مراسله الجزيره بيسان ابو كويك اذن
بيسان الملف انتقل الى المحكمه ولكن هل
بذلك يمكن ازداد الستار على قضيه بهذا
الحجم
حسن طبعا يعني ربما تاثيرات وتداعيات
عمليه تسريب هذه الوثائق
المباشره وغير المباشره ما زالت ربما قيد
الدراسه او غير معروفه حتى هذه اللحظه ان
كان من حيث تاثيراتها الخارجيه على
الولايات المتحده او حتى داخليا بالنظر
الى تمكن شاب يبلغ من العمر 21 عاما نعم
كان يعمل كاختصاصي في التكنولوجيا في وحده
الاستخبارات في الحرس الوطني لولايه ماست
شوس ولكنه يعني هناك تساؤلات كيف تمكن
وفقا لرتبته من الحصول على كل هذه
الوثائق السريه عاليه السريه وان كان
بالفعل ربما الاعتمادات والتصريحات التي
كان يملكها كانت تتيح له الحصول على ذلك
وسهوله نشر ذلك عب هذه الغرف التي كان
يرتادها
الكترونيا شبان مهتمون
بقضيه يعني الالعاب او العاب الفيديو
نتوقع طبعا حسن هذا الصباح
يمثل جاك تشيره ليس لدينا موعد محدد بعد
ولكن على الارجح صبيحه هذا اليوم هنا في
هذه المحكمه امام قادم على خلفيه هذه
القضيه طبعا على الارجح حين يمثل امام
القاضي سيتم توجيه تهم له ولكن في
تصريحات المقتضبه التي ادلى بها وزير
العدل الامريكي ماري جورد
بالامس اشار الى انه تم القبض عليه على
خلفيه التحقيقات
متعلقه
بالازاله غير الشرعيه والحفاظ والنشر
معلومات ووثائق استخباراتيه متعلقه بالامن
القومي الامريكي وهنا اشاره الى قانون
التجسس الذي يعود الى عام
1917 لذا التوقعات ان تم توجيه التهم له
ان يكون وفقه ما ينص عليه هذا القانون
هناك ايضا يعني معلومات تشير الى انه بعد
موصوله هنا على الارجح سينقل الى منطقه
العاصمه واشنطن لاستكمال الاجراءات
القضائيه هناك ولكن حتى الان لا يوجد جدول
زمني محدد لكل ذلك حسن
شكرا جزيلا لك بسنه ابو كويك كنت معنا من
بوسطن